上课啊，同学们。
咱们上节课录的时候，我记得还穿着短袖呢。
几克棉袄都整上了。
有同学说，那就是你以为你更新太慢了呀，是吧？脱更时间太长了，真不是是北京的天气变化太快了。前几天真的在穿短袖呀，突然就冷了。而且咱们北方这个天气啊，本北方本来秋天就短。
然后这个冷了之后，到供暖之前，这十几二十天是最难熬的。所以在这在在屋里也觉得非常冷，没有办法，对吧？穿棉袄给大家录课。
来戴个帽子。
我今天戴这个帽子呀。
我同事说我像个地主。
嘲讽我。
这你们就真不懂了，这叫啥帽子，你们知道吗？
这叫杀手帽。
这个杀手不太冷，里面让雷诺戴的帽子呀，杀手帽呀，没有那个杀手的气质吗？为什么说是杀手帽？这帽子是7班一个同学送给我的。
放在我们公司前台送给我的。
然后跟我说，这是让雷诺同款。
哎。
同学们以后不要这样做啊，就是不要因为有好多同学知道我的这个这个这个知道我在哪之后呢，给我给我寄东西，给我发东西什么的。
呃，不不需要啊，特别是那些吃的什么乱七八糟的。
哎，其实不我你知道我爱吃什么吗？其这这咱们这个学习啊，咱们咱们是个网课。
咱们其实都是在网上算是。
有了这个师途情移，对吧？
没有必要搞得那么复杂没有必要搞得那么复杂，你们也不知道我喜欢什么就。
我喜欢别墅。
我喜欢奔驰是吧？不要给我其他的东西，我都不会喜欢的，好吗？
然后还有前段时间。
那个教师节的时候，教师节那天大量的同学给我发红包。
哎呀。
我一个也没有点开，同学们，我一个也没有点开你们的红包。
不是老师，我不喜欢钱，对吧？我吹那个牛逼干什么，说我不喜欢钱吗？
不是我不喜欢钱。
是我知道红包的极限呀。
对吧。
不值得一点。
所以咱们这个同学啊，特别是学习群里的同学，咱们现在班级群越来越庞大，有这么多同学，对吧？咱们光这个学习群里有。
只有一万个同学了。
不要成天给我搞事情，对吧？你们觉得给我发个红包，或者给我寄点东西，很麻烦的，我都很烦的对吧？我们好好学习就可以了。
你们学会写剧本，我就很开心了。
好吧。
啊，对，说到咱们这个学习群啊，在这里我要感谢一下这个咱们的班委会，咱们每个班都有班长，每个班至少都有一个班长帮着同学们去呃发资料呀、收作业呀、组织考试呀，有时候还答疑呀。
这些班长。
都是和其他同学一样，也其实也都是我的学生，没有一个是我的员工。
他们做这个事情呢也都是。
完全义务的。
为爱发电。所以在这里我非常感谢我们的班委会，这些同学的付出。
啊，最近有一个好消息就是我给咱们的编剧课找了一个算是教务主任嘛。
嗯，现在他已经潜伏到每一个班班级里面去了。
呃，他来干啥呢？因为他是专门是做这个编剧。
教育的一直做这个编剧教育的教务工作的课程设计工作的。所以我请他来呢帮我们的课程的质量呀、节奏呀，把把关给我们出出招。
我相信在他的帮助下，我们可以。
更高效更快速的学习吧。我是这么想的啊，咱们之前人少的时候，我还经常布置作业，现在我都不敢布置了。我觉得那有由教务主任来了之后梳理每个班级，再加上班委会的配合，我们还是应该继续开始布置作业。
这个也很重要，练习非常重要，我不布止，我怕有些同学不写。
好吧，所以这节课结束的时候提醒我一下，让我布置作业。
啊，另外咱这个教务主任来了之后呢。
嗯，他跟我说这个这个他有可能想组织一些。
咱们同学的线下活动，因为光在网上可能教学的效果没有那么好，那就看他安排吧。
可能最开始的时候会从北京先开始，因为毕竟我们在北京嘛。
从北京先开始，到时候。
呃，听主任安排吧。
咱们呢就继续咱们的。
课程。
按部就班的学，大家认真学好吧。
然后这节课讲点啥呢？
这节课呢其实我是想讲一个。
非常非常重要的问题。
但是这个问题。
跟上节课一样，还是需要大家已经有基础了。你前面的课认认真真学了，你也认认真真写过自己的东西了，自己写过剧本了。
你才能学这一节课。
因为这一节课非常有针对性。
哎。
这节课叫啥呢？
叫。
高潮上不去的问题。
我们解决这个问题。
这个问题我跟大家说是非常普遍的。
非常普遍的，为什么呢？
是因为我看了大大量大家写的剧本。
普遍在高潮这里啊，往往就是一句话。
就是一句话说就是。
我们的英雄通过殊死搏斗，最终战胜了坏蛋。
这场戏确实是高潮戏，没毛病。高潮戏就是这个内容。
但是呢。
不会展开了。
或者他不知道怎么写了。
就撂在那，我问他，我说那这一段戏到底是怎么决战呢？分多少场呢？他不知道。
那你等谁给你写呢？
从我给你写。
还是等导演和和读者给你设计吗？
对吧他跟我说，那就是打戏呗，让他咣咣打打的越精彩越好，交给导演和五指吧。
不是这样的啊，同学们。
高潮戏也是我们需要解决的。
而且高潮戏啊。
理论上来说啊。
高潮戏是你这个剧本，你这个故事最重要的一个环节。
其实是最重要的一个环节啊，同学们。
你前面啊你看啊，我们先说高潮戏是哪一段高潮戏施哪一段？
如果按照三布式。
建制对抗解决。
高潮系。
就是解决那里。
解决问题那里啊。
如果按照。
思耐德节拍器。哎，我们讲过斯耐德节拍器，同学们还记得哈。
按照斯奈德节拍系。
高潮戏是哪一段？
是。
首先有个第三步衔接点。
对不对？然后呢。
灵魂黑夜。
然后。
高潮解决问题。
等于是。
从危机以后。
一直到。
高潮。
从危机转到多潮？
是按照节拍器是那道内轱辘。
实际就是啥呢？实际是就是你这个电影的最后半小时，就你这个电影如果长的话啊。
差不多是最后半小时。如果你这个电影你就就就100分钟或者100挂铃，那就是最后二十来分钟了。
最后二十来分钟。
其实就是第四节嘛。
四目式的第四节启程转河的和。
这个地方就是最大危机来了之后，到你怎么解决这个危机，其实就叫。
高潮汐。
这戏为什么重要？
你自己琢磨琢磨嘛。
你前面介绍人物铺垫人物，对吧？制造问题，制造危机，制造悬念，制造转折，最后不就为了这一下吗？
最后不就为了这一件吗？
是不是？
就是这你如果这一下整不明白，那你前面陪他逛街，请他喝咖啡吃饭，看电影全全都白扯了，明白这个意思吧，全都白扯了。
全都白扯了。
所以说。
高潮戏理论上啊是一个电影最重要的部分。
因为它是解决问题的部分，你前面谋划布局，这个这个各种铺垫，为了就是最后这一场戏。
而且从电影的角度来讲，这场戏往往也是最花钱的，烧钱全部烧在这场戏了。
对吧。
然后从观看的角度来讲呢。
观众是看完这场戏离场的。
是带着这个情绪延续离场的。
也就是说这这是观众对你的印象。
高潮没高潮是观众对你的印象，前面都白扯。刚才是吃的麻辣烫还是吃的西餐，不重要了。最后这场戏。
对吧他是带着这场戏的满足感和对你的评价。
回家的，所以这场是个千万不能搞砸了啊，千万不能搞砸了。
就是这么重要。
就是这么重要，大家理解这个意思就行了啊。咱们以后这个上课啊。
尽量。
少开黄腔，对吧？因为有一些毕竟有很多女女同学开黄腔，对女同学不礼貌啊，我们尽量以后尽量少少。
烧开。
那么就来说一下这节课我们就来说一下这个高潮系，你这个高潮序上不去的问题怎么解决？因为咱们大部分的同学啊精心谋划自己。
这个戏的铺垫阶段，建制阶段，然后各种构建起来，哎呀，像一张网一样，你知道吗？各种设计。
然后到了真正要劲儿的时候呢，轻飘飘就过去了。
轻飘飘就过去了。
你明白我意思吧？
那你给别人的感受肯定是不好的呀。
这个问题咋解决呢？
这个问题其实。
我自己也经常遇到这样的问题。
这节课我们就来研究一下。
这个问题咋解决？
首先我们先得明确一个思路啊。
这里不能全部交给打戏。
因为有很多电影他没有打戏啊，对吧？你不能全部交给打戏，即便是有打戏，也不能完全交给无指啊，你就没你事了，交给吴指，让他去设计，我们主角跟反派打的从天上打到地下，从地上打到房上上窜下跳，对吧？这个陆地上打一会儿，水里打一会儿。
树上再打一会儿。
不是这么玩的啊，所以咱们先得明确这个问题。然后还有一个问题我想提出来跟家大家探讨一下，就是关于这场高潮戏怎么打，或者是怎么解决，怎么对抗这场高潮戏是先有还是后有的问题。这个问题呢是有争议的。
有很多编剧认为。
这场戏既然是最重要的那你如果这场戏没有设计好。
就说最后怎么合题，怎么合上，怎么解决这场戏得先设计。
得先设计设计好了之后呢。
你才能写剧本。
这样的话，你不就可以有意的为后面这场戏。
开始搞一些铺垫悬念伏笔设计吗？
有很多人是这样认为。
有道理有一定道理。
但我觉得呢。
不绝对。
你也可以写到那儿的时候再解决。
就是说你先有个很好的设定呀。
先有个很好的设定。
同学们记不记得我曾经在有一课里面，在很早期的有一课里面，我那节课叫什么？
我有一节课给大家讲如何下手一个故事。
就你这个故事。
下手点支点，对吧？我讲过这么一课。
我讲这么一课，其实我的理念就是你先找到一个下手点，一个很好的身份。
一个很好的悬念，一个很好的激励，一个很好的二次动作，对吧？或者是一个很好的环境也好，对吧？反正你找到一个很棒的下手点，你就先写。
你就先写，你说我想写一个想要殉职的警察，你一听哎呀一想到这个主意的时候，你就一拘灵一拘灵。然后你觉得哎，我操我这个剧本有门了，我开始写。那至于最后他死没死，跟谁决战，那场戏打了几分，怎么打的精彩。
你其实还是没有想好的。
你也可以写。
你谢谢。
然后我这节课就教你，如果是我们先有设定，先写拉到那场戏，你就是写不出解决方案了。
咋办？
你可不能给我写这个这个警察与歹徒英勇搏斗，最后壮烈牺牲写了10个字，就告诉我，这是最后的第四幕，那不行啊，不能一律而过，对吧？要劲儿的时候，你他妈没劲儿了，是吧？前面他妈喝咖啡的时候，你话挺多。
呃，来，我们就解决这个问题啊，所以我说是可以的，可以先做设定，可以先写其他的。我们这节课就叫它高潮部分，好吧，到高潮部分这里呢。
解决问题这里呢。
呃，我们是有办法的。
我们是有办法的那我们就先来分析一下所谓高潮系，也就是所谓的解决这个部分。
这个戏都有些什么样的特点？
就这部分的戏它需要什么样的特点，什么样的功能。
你不就知道该怎么写了吗？
对吧。
嗯。
这些因为都是我总结的，所以他们有可能不是严格的并列关系，或者是不是整数，不是说高潮系实定律或者是八原则，不一定是整数。所以大家就是理解意思就可以了。好吧，有几个咱们就整几个。
第一个。
首先。
高潮戏是。
叫满足。
满足观众的期待。
满足。
观众的期待，这是高潮戏的作用。
但是后面还有一句叫。
用它。
没想到的方式。
就是你得满足观众的期待，但是用他没想到的方式。
就我可以送到那了。
但是这个招你可能没见过，我给你到位了啊，但是招你可能没见过，这就是一个。
好的高潮系。
好了高潮袭，首先你得满足他的期待，他想要什么，你真得给他。
但是呢招。
他没见过。
这是第一个原则。
其实啊就是回报观众嘛，我们说高潮戏就是回报嘛，回馈观众回报观众，你前面整那么多人家哎，你一个电影假设个120分钟，我说那这个高潮部分如果是120分钟，他就是最后30分钟或者25分钟嘛，人家陪着你在这做了。
95分钟10分钟啦。
你得回报他。
回报他呢就是得满足他的基本期待。
但是用一种他没有想到的方式。
这是。
高潮系的。
第一个原则。
顺序不分先后啊，我也就是想到什么说什么。
高潮系的第二个特征。
就是。
节奏。
提上来了。
节奏提上来了。
节奏加快。
我们说整个到。
第四幕到解决这一部分啊。
他的节奏是要加快的。
然后。
在好多份教材里面都用一个词形容高潮系顶到这里的时候是什么呢？叫螺旋上升。
叫情绪螺旋上升，但是弦儿越来越小，越来越快。假设你你在布局这个戏的时候啊，本来是这么玩的对吧？然后我上这个就哎。
脑子里能想象出这个画面吗？
像屎不是像屎像那个越来越细的弹簧，就螺旋上升。
哎，一下就顶上去了。
这个大家去去去去多去理解啊。
但是到高潮的时候，节奏有点加快，你们是是是能理解的啊，就螺旋上升，就是情绪螺旋上升是这么一个状态。这个在好几们教材里面都提到这个词，所以我觉得有必要先拎出来给大家讲一讲。
节奏越来越快，螺旋上升。
到了第四幕啊。
不能稀里马糊的，对吗？不能拉稀败带。
是吧巴西拜代是哪个电影里面听的词儿忘了啊，反正就是这个这个节奏要加快。
要注意节奏问题。好吧，这是关于高潮戏的第二个问题。
第三个问题。
我们叫。
兑现所有伏笔。
悬念。
就你先前面所有埋的扣挖的坑，悬念复伏笔。
这里全部要填掉了。
全部要填掉了。
好吧，第四。
叫。
再次意外。
再次出现意外。
这个就有点。
不好理解了啊。
怎么给你们讲呢？想想看啊。
就是说你这里我当然知道你的咱们的主角要跟。
坏人做最后的决战。
不一定是打戏，但都是最后的决战的意思。
这时候。
还是要再次制造意外。
或者叫反转。
反转。
或者叫反转啊。
再次出现意外。
但然这个意外呢，你不能生反。
你不能生反，比如说最后这场决战，我们的主角。
冲上去。
要跟这个对手大决战。
然后你就来一个生反生生的反转说咦。
坏人不是他搞错了再来，那不行，你前面的买好伏笔了，说坏人不是他，至少提前。
提前两趴让观众知道了。
最后的对手不是我们主角认为的这个。
然后呢，搞错了。
或者是。
你不能说啊，我们主角今天。
要去跟坏人大决战。
家里精心准备，然后去要跟他决战。
然后刚要开枪发现忘了带子弹。
你那你这个反转也是太突然太无厘头。
你忘了带子弹，必须你前面。
充分的铺垫了主角身边有内奸，给他把子弹。
偷了换了，明白吧？
就是说再次出现意外和反转，但是呢也是要兑现其实也是一定程度上兑现前面的伏笔。
就是不能生反啊，这个意外要有铺垫的。
明白吗？
这个待会儿我给大家讲几个案例，具体说吧。好吧，第五。
裂度问题。
烈度问题。
到这场戏了。
咱就不要客气了。
不要搂着了。
我说过的增加烈度的方法，大家可以用上了，对不对？我曾经在两次考试中出过烈度题。
出过烈度题啊。
参加过七班选拔考试，咱们的实验班选拔考试的同学。
哎，或者是其他同学也可以去，咱们的卷子都公开了是吧？对，凡是在咱们这个这个学习群的同学，可以问班委会，问班长要一下之前考试。
考过的卷子大家去看一下。
关于烈度，我考过两回。
因为很重要。
很重要，在这里在这场戏，关于剧情烈度，你就造吧。
再裂也不过分。
你只要别无厘头啊，再造也不过分。
这场戏是需要烈度的。
整起来好吧，然后第六个方面。
叫。
叫主角的。
抉择问题。
主角的抉择问题。
我之前在课上啊听课认真的同学。
我之前在课上，我好像提过主角，在他的旅程当中至少有两次抉择。
而且抉择的时候往往是伴随着自我牺牲的。
第一次抉择呢是。
第二幕上路的时候。
对吧。
你第一幕是激励事件把你给击走了。
吸收了之后呢，他反复击你。
我们说从12到25分钟嘛，反复挤你，现状不可接受。
现状不可接受之后，你在25分钟觉得一拍大腿，去他妈的对吧？我要离家出走，我要去找我亲妈，那是一次抉择，那是一次小抉择。那第二次抉择呢就是大抉择，就是在高潮系这里。高潮戏我们说。
解决用那个节拍器的说法，其实是危机和高潮。但其实啊我们说斯奈德的节拍器把危机和高潮分的挺开的。
但其实在相当相当一部分故事里面，大危机就是伴随着大高潮。
就大危机来了之后啊，你是没有时间回家准备准备的。
没有时间谋划谋划的。
有的故事有。
但是有很多故事，危机和高潮是并生的。
就是大危机来的那一场，也就是。
我们主角的大高潮系。
他来的很突然嘛，对吧？你没有什么那么多时间去准备。
所以说在这场戏里面。
我们主角要应对这个危机。
他有的时候是会有重大抉择的。
重大抉择呢就会带来呃自我牺牲自我牺牲。
所以高潮系里面这个东西也是不可忽视的。
而且还有在有一节课里面，我给大家也提过一个问题。
你看咱的课都是都是它是成体系的啊，同学们你得你就得好好听，记得这些我跟你说过的话才行呀。我我我我不知道在哪一节，反正我说过主角到这场戏的时候，一定要主角自己面对问题。
自己解决问题。
对吧他在这里他有抉择和自我牺牲，他要来解决最终的危机。
问题。
解决大高潮问题。
在这里呀就不要再来天外来客了。
对吧从天而降，一个什么人拯救了他。
或者是。
从天而降一个技能，又学会了一招，然后啊用这个。
呃，新的技能把对方给干掉了。凡是如果要有新技能在这里习得，这个技能必须是最初就给着他了。
同学们记得吧？我在课上说过。
这个技能不可能是在这儿给他的，是早就给你了。
早就给你了，你只是不会用如来神掌这个秘籍，我早就给你了。
你前面没悟透啊。
所以说在这里啊非常忌讳。
天外来客非常忌讳新技能。
新变量不要引入新变量了，在高潮系这里越单纯越好。
你自己顶不上去，你也不能找别人来帮忙吧。
是是。
这不不可以的，是不是你不可能说我哎，我帮我找个外援，对吧？或者是我我我又获得新道具了。
那也不行那也不行，自己解决好吧，你自己去直面这个问题。所以在有的教材里面，他还有一个呃词儿说这里呢主角再次自我挖潜。
对吧因为你也不能让别人解决问题，然后呢，你的主角明明又解决不了这个问题，解决不了这个危机，那你咋办呢？就是再次自我挖潜嘛，再回去翻一翻，这个如来神掌我之前好像没看懂，咦，现在看懂了，对吧？现在看懂或者是受到别的刺激。
反正是要主角自我挖钱。
再次抉择啊，自我牺牲。
好吧。
这是第几个了啊，第6个。
第7个。
那就是。
最重要的一个问题非常非常重要的一个问题就是。
AB合题的问题。
AB互是合题的问题。
我们讲过AB故事吧，讲过人物胡光吧。我跟同学们讲过啊，A是人物外在的旅程，外在的旅程啊。
B故事是人物内在的成长，内心的成长，一个外在，一个内在，对吧？外在的呢有时候是。
虚的内在的呢。
反而更实。
外在呢有时候是肤浅的，内在呢才是根本的。
在。
高潮系这里。
你如果发现我操我的高潮系不咋地，那你给我检查检查你有没有做到AB合体这件事情。
在这里，因为我们说解决最后的解决嘛，最后的解决嘛，解决所有的问题，你AB故事在这里要合题了。我不管你之前A和B分的有多开，A和B有多么的并驾齐驱。这里。
合体。
合起来。
究竟是。
A都满足了。
还是摒弃了A，选择了B。
在这里都给出一个答案了。
给出一个答案了。所以说AB和体这个问题。
我简单拉了一下。
基本上从这7个方面入手。
我认为可以解决你的高潮无力的问题。
不要在在以后在前面写了一个精彩的设定，哇，精彩的人物各种伏笔。到了最后这场就说我们的主角勇于面对，跟谁一同搏斗，对吧？这个这个。
这个出现这种高潮乏力的情况。
高潮无力的情况。
通过这7个方面解决一下，好吧，第一个方面。
就是满足观众的期待，但是用他没有想到的方式，先回报观众，回报观众所有的期待。第二呢把节奏提起来。
到了这里，明确的把节奏提起来，心里要上着这根弦儿。
第三。
兑现你前面所有埋过的伏笔和悬念，该有报应，有报应，该炸雷炸雷，对吧？都兑现。第四，一定要注意这一场不能顺，还是要有再次有意外，再次有反转。
第五，我教过你们的增加烈度的方式，全部给他招呼上，不用客气了，对吧？到这儿你就别客气了，是不是饭也吃了，咖啡也喝了，电影也看了。
妈还买了一个周大福是吧？别客气了，还客气什么？
是不是上嘛，然后6这个主角的抉择。
就是这里呢一定要牢牢记住，是我们的主角解决问题，谁也不好使。来到这里就主角解决问题，主角自己亲自来。
既然他要亲自来这里有一次大的抉择，或者说要再次抉择，会有自我牺牲。然后呢。
面对不了这个问题，解决不了这个问题怎么办呢？自我挖潜。
自己激发自己的潜力啊，或者是别人激发他的潜力啊，那二死了，那二死了不就激发你的潜力了吗？是不是激发你的潜力？然后第七也是最容易被忽略的一个问题，就是AB合体的问题，对吧？这个事情关于。
关系到不光是你的故事精彩的问题，更重要是关系到你这个剧本最后豆瓣评分的问题。AB故事故事。我跟你说啊，大家去看豆瓣评分高的电影，全都是AB故事合体的电影。
你只要把AB故事。
做的清晰有力，然后相互呼应。最后一合题，你的片子整个气质嘚的一下就上去了。你的豆瓣评分也能就是AE只要一合题，豆瓣平地就多骗1点5分，多骗1.5分，这是我们长期总结出来的经验啊，就AB不是合题的问题。
嗯嗯。
我给大家讲几个例子吧，否则大家理解起来有点困难。我们就看我们说高潮系是啥，高潮系就是第四幕这个解决的这一部分，对吧？也就是节拍里面从危机到高潮这一块。
给大家讲几个例子，但是呢都是我们之前课上讲过的例子，避免新的呃这个例子来干扰大家了。我们就用之前我给大家举过的一些影片，好吧。
我们先看几个文戏，文戏的高潮戏，大家不是。
这个这个这个不会写吗？我们先看几个文戏，人家是怎么做的。
第一个。
定制霸郎。
海文哈特那个定制半拉。
我在课上给大家讲过，对吧？
大家先看一下。
他的后面这个结尾戏。
He to death. Do you part.
哎，对。
I now pronounce you.
Husband and wife。
没那有kiss the bird。
Ladies and gentlemen, I present to you Mr. and Mrs. Harris.
I'm myself up there in Canada kind of stuff do you that's when I knew I was born to work on You're a podiatrist, I'm a podiatrist.
这不是去 go to school。
You remember Harvard I went to Harvard, I'm really inspired by like black American so singerers like Tom Jones, you went to Harvard dry his school for years 2020.
Oh wow, here we go hu isn't Tom Jones White, Yeah, is he from Wales?
妈。
Oh my god, oh my god, my god, you want to boom three balls count them。
他到决赛局是那个。
OK that's cool真.
叫什么？
complete zipper Harris talk a I'll get listen I may be partial here but I just want to say that you put the perfect wedding wedding the zipper on my$8000 dress broken the groom men are aosing my bridesmas my grandmother's burned from head to toe dad's knee is shredded and don't even get me started on a solid dressing.
But least have true love all true love please I'm just sick of dating asholes Doug is a good's good family material What can I say I'm a girl that's certain kind of lifestyle cant lifestyle What' the problem I think I made a terrible.
s you why say that I over the two of you talking.
you evening my is and I to say honor to be Doug and I been through a together times.
I can honestly say that.
I've never had a friend to make me feel the way that you have done.
II'm sorryry啊。
When Doug called me and told me that he wanted to propose, he told me he asked.
Just stop thanks.
哎。
I've got something to say.
None of this is real.
嗯嗯。
What we're not married Gretch and I we can't be because my friend V is not a Yeah, in fact is' not even in the army. His real name is Jimmy and I hired him to be my best man because I had no other options same with all my groom I actually don't even know their real last name to you guys So please say and enjoy the cake.
We need to get the fuck out of here.
。
猪蛋面冰前面 mother.
this close dog, Yeah, well, maybe next time.
哦。
有。
save me Jimmymy here well, you saved me to.
By the way, did you mean what you said back there?
Am I really a friend.
什问题。
'O, I want this moneyI earn this money。
So what the hell do you do now?你 forgot got those two first lessons things from me honeymoon That and did.
我们说定制伴郎啊，他的故事我用几句话简单给大家说一下，就是一个孤独的小胖子要结婚，但是他没有朋友，他怕女方瞧不起他，他就花钱雇人假装自己的伴郎。最后呢他跟他花钱雇来的这个伴郎之间本来是一个雇佣关系，但是最后两个人真的成为了好朋友。
两个孤独的灵魂真的相互依靠了。然后他还发现他这个女朋友。
并不咋地，最后他决定啊不结这个婚了。
不结这个婚了。
就这么个故事。那他最后这场戏无疑。
高潮系就职这场婚礼。
就是他俩精心准备的这场婚礼，他要假扮他的伴郎，然后他呢要迎娶一个非常非常漂亮的姑娘。
然后这场婚礼戏就是这个电影的高潮戏。我们说你看这场高潮戏他都做了哪些？
东西。
首先有意外吧。
精心准备，但是最后还是差点要穿帮了。
那个新娘方女方发现了这些伴郎都有问题啊，好像不是他朋友，名字也怪怪的，行为也怪怪的，就再次出现意外。
对吧然后呢。
有没有反转？
不结了，婚都不结了，对吧？还结什么婚？
选择了友情，不要这个爱情了不要这个假爱情了，对吧？
然后节奏就不用说了，这场戏节奏开始提的非常快。
然后主角的抉择和牺牲。
这个电影是做的非常好的。
他明确的做出了选择。
直面自己的问题。然后呢。
呃，摒弃了这段贪慕虚荣的爱情，对吧？做出了重大的抉择和牺牲，而且是主角自己做出来的，是那小胖子自己做出来的。
最重要的我们要其实要还是要看AB合题的问题。AB合题的问题。
他的A故事是什么？
A故事是顾伴郎。
对吧哈。
就我们的主角那个小胖子，他的A故事是雇一个伴郎假装自己的好朋友，这是他的A故事。
雇个伴郎，假装自己的好朋友。
B故事呢，我们说A是外在的那B就是内在的外在的他是雇一个假伴郎，假装自己的好朋友。那B故事必然就是找一个真正的好朋友呀。
AB是相对的嘛，一外以内嘛，A是找一个假朋友，B就是找一个真朋友。
合题了吧。
合尚了呀，他找到了真朋友了呀。
而且他是选择了比丙弃雷在这里。
就是我假扮郎不要了，我连婚都不结了，我不需要伴郎了，但我要一个真朋友。
科题。
这就是定制伴郎。